so cool congratulations to you guys on
launching this
it's it's a big deal um i'll start with
you know what first question is um can
you tell us about
this organization and its goal
yeah i mean you know the impetus of
uh you know the black academy really
started with life or not for profit
which is an acronym for building a
legacy
and acting cinema and knowledge and you
know that's something we started in 2016
because
you know i think chemin and i recognize
this gap
uh you know between you know canada
really supporting
uh uh you know the talent that comes out
of canada
you know canada and so you know often we
see so many situations of
you know our talent having to you know
garner some sort of success
south of the border before they're even
appreciated
uh you know in their own home and so you
know we wanted to end this perpetual
loop that exists and and and so it
started as this small party
uh that we do in conjunction with tip
every year but really
um it's grown into this now national
effort
uh to you know celebrate uh elevate
uh you know black talent all over canada
i love that um shamir so this is a new
division of your established
community-based non-for-profit
black canada but how will the black
academy further your ability to give
back
we got so many incredible talented
individuals doing incredible things not
just in the arts but in
the science fields sports fields
cultural i mean everything
and to honor individuals like yourself
keisha who have built such a legacy
at home you know what people have have
have
been able to do what they can do because
of individuals like yourself and this is
why staphon and i were so excited to sit
down with you
because we were in bay mills in metro
housing watching you you know really
watching you and that's the truth and
times were so different you know back
then and to be able to see the legacy
that you have built
it's important that the world can
appreciate that and appreciate legends
like yourself
that have really paved the way and this
is why we built an incredible board of
directors
from vanessa craft former
editor-in-chief of l down to west hall
bay street bully dr tonya williams a
pioneer
who really you know was groundbreaking
and opening up a lot of doors for many
of us on the zoo today
so this is why it's important on the
national scale while we're launching the
black academy
you know today as a division of our
not-for-profit black
that's incredible thank you um you do
have some wonderful women a part of this
can you tell us why you had to get these
two women involved because
i mean tanya vanessa they're brilliant
let's talk about that absolutely i mean
you know tanya williams you know we
don't have to say much about her she
you know she's a pioneer we call her the
godmother
you know she literally she literally
paved the way and i won't say her age
but she does not look her age
like phenomenal when i say black don't
crack
i don't know um but but you know
jennifer honest
uh vanessa crabbe look we were we were
raised by a single mother in bay mills
you know in scarborough
so you know it's not lost on us the
importance of
uh women and what they've been able to
do for our life
um and so you know we we know that we're
gonna be able to look
to these strong powerful women who are
each leaders in their various
you know sectors and have been doing
some version of this work
you know prior to engaging on this board
and so
um you know we're proud to say that you
know our board uh consists of these
women
uh mostly women at this point in time
and and i don't think it's done
quite yet i know that this is just
getting
launched but you know is there dreams
are there goals for this to become an
international thing
um are you hopeful that this can extend
beyond canada or is the primary focus
canadian talent the primary focus right
now is going to be canadian talent
as we just begin to to build this out
it's important to take a minute for
canadian talent blackening
and not rush i mean we love our american
counterparts but
it's also important to note that we've
seen their world
10 times over and we are inundated with
it every day whether it be good
bad ugly beautiful you know it's all
great
but the reality is we got to take a
moment for us and this is for
us and by us and this is why we are
founding this for us
and then obviously the bigger dreams you
know definitely we look at guys like
oprah
um women i should say like oprah guys
like tyler perry
and seeing what they're doing expanding
and of course in the later years we
could definitely have
michelle obama coming in and saying a
special word and presenting
akisha schnatten with an award of some
sort okay
that's definitely the scope we want to
start on the grass roots
and in the weeds and really build our
community here and help build
you know and help you know foster that
talent and create programming and
and most importantly call out on our
government leaders to help us with this
call a corporate candidate to help us
with this and not to stand behind us and
just you know cut a check in the back
like really
be with us and be be that voice and i
think it's important to stress that
um and really building ally ship and
just disrupting the system and
redesigning the space as the tectonic
plates are shifting in the entertainment
industry and we want to be the conduit
of that change
i love that um obviously this year has
been
very trying particularly for the black
community
are you guys hopeful for the future are
you
seeing shifts happening um right now at
all
yeah i mean look you know i can say that
you know with the launch of this black
academy i'm more hopeful today than i
was yesterday
um you know i think that schumer and
myself got to a point
that you know we just weren't satisfied
with you know our own personal success
and it's easy to just you know sit here
in los angeles and pretend like nothing
else is happening but
you know the reality is when you find
yourself
you know being one of just a handful of
individuals who have been able to do
what you're able to do
and to have that transcend into
uh uh you know into america and to the
rest of the world
um decision to make uh what am i going
to
do about that you know i'm going to let
the the bug stop at me
and my brother or are we going to look
to the next generation and say we want
to provide you with the
the tools and the resources that we
never had uh to be able to take
your craft uh as far as you wanna take
it
and and and so you know we really made a
concerted effort to choose
the latter and and choose to to get back
in our
to to our community in this way and this
is really just um
you know a drop in the bucket of that
work but uh
you know i gotta say that i am more
hopeful now knowing that
you know my people will be able to see
themselves because
to to to be it you have to see it
they'll see themselves recognized and
appreciated
um in the way that they're supposed to
be um and that can only breed
um you know unimaginable inspiration for
the next generation
i'm so proud of y'all
[Laughter]
let your mama know i say you guys are
great
i'm sure she hears it all the time but
no you guys are always doing incredible
things
and what people need to understand too
is that y'all are busy
you guys work a lot on so many projects
i'm always seeing something in the news
about one of you guys
doing something or taking on a new
project so to be able to take the time
out to give back
in this way and not just uh like you
were saying it's not like a quick write
a check
or you know a quick interview or saying
you know co-signing an event
you guys are putting together a
foundation in
canada to really take care of people
this is like the beginning of something
really magical so
kudos to you guys it's a big deal thank
you
appreciate it um so you both are
extremely busy
i know one of you is doing a film with
tom hardy and pete davidson
i mean what can you tell us about that
excuse you
oh man look i'm excited tom hardy to me
um you know gotta be one of my favorite
actors ever period so same
uh you know i i was uh i was pretty
dumbfounded when i found myself on a
zoom with him a couple weeks ago
talking about this film so i'm just
really really excited the things they
carry
uh 2021 we're really really excited
about us a great
great director i get to go in the
trenches with uh with one of the greats
and i'm just looking forward to it
you